ok acht monate knapp 500.000 kalorien in
über 500 mahlzeiten
ich werde mich jetzt liegen und immer
gespannt was es gebracht hat
[Musik]
das wird ein sehr persönliches video
ich habe mich in meiner haut
fast immer unwohl gefühlt also ich bin
selbstbewusst und ich stehe gerne vor
der kamera und all das ja aber ich war
immer für mein gefühl übergewichtig noch
übrigens vom bmi hält wirklich was ist
der bmi aussagt über verschiedene körper
gerichtet anderes thema aber ich
persönlich wollte abnehmen ich wollte
eigentlich immer dünner sein als ich die
großteil der zeit war und
dass ich habe das jetzt geschafft aber
das hat nur wenig mit dem zu tun wo es
in diesem video geht sondern auch ganz
viel mit psychologie und darum wollen
wir nicht gehen das hat er nicht
verloren aber es gab einige dinge die
muss ich erst mal klären bei mir und die
mussten erstmal in place fallen damit
ich mich öffnen konnte und erst die
motivation hatte und alles andere was
noch passieren musste um mit dem
gewichtsverlust anzufangen denn gewicht
zu verlieren ist sehr simpel aber
überhaupt nicht einfach
ich hoffe ich kann euch mit diesem video
hier die richtigen werkzeuge an die hand
geben wie man entweder gewicht zunehmen
kann das geht auch oder gewicht
verlieren kann aber das wichtigste ist
natürlich erst mal wenn ihr so seit wir
sowieso schon sein wollt dann müsst ihr
gar nichts tun ich will niemandem das
gefühl geben dass ihr zu viel oder zu
wenig da was auch immer wiegt und wenn
ihr was verändern wollt dann müsst ihr
jetzt erstmal psychologisch mit euch im
reinen sein ihr müsst einen guten place
sein sonst funktioniert das alles nicht
und es ist motivation nicht da und dass
deutschland nicht haben red wings at
hier ist was ich
[Musik]
habe im januar 2021 angefangen jeder
einzelne kalorien zu zählen die ich zu
mir nehme und spoiler ich habe damit
eine menge abgenommen wie habe ich das
gemacht tatsächlich mit wissenschaft
kalorien sind nämlich nichts anderes als
eine maßeinheit von energie und klar
zeigen sollte man als wissenschaftler er
mit schularbeiten aber kalorien
beziehungsweise ja eigentlich die
meisten fällt kilokalorien sind eben im
alltag einfach typischer auf jeder
verpackung steht irgendwo der brennwert
der angibt wie viel energie eine
bestimmte menge von diesem lebensmittel
hat und energie braucht unser körper
eben für fast alles selbst wenn ich den
ganzen tag entspannt zu hause auf dem
sofa rum liege und netflix gucke schlägt
mein herz denkt mein gehirn und atmet
meine lunge und nebenbei muss auch noch
die körpertemperatur auf demselben
niveau gehalten werden ich atme und
denke aber nicht mehr als 24 stunden am
tag wäre eigentlich ganz praktisch man
kann ich leider nicht und das bedeutet
es gibt eine bestimmte menge an kalorien
die ich am tag brauche und genau da
macht uns unser körper leider einen
strich durch die rechnung
[Musik]
etwas anderes das auch energie braucht
ist mein auto kann damit rum fahren und
fahren den akku leer und wenn ich dann
wieder weiterfahren will dann muss ich
wieder aufladen nur leider funktioniert
mein körper ja ein bisschen anders ich
kann ja mehr essen als ich am tag
brauche mehr laden quasi ich kann über
100 prozent laden und dann setze ich
fett an was vielleicht in der heutigen
gesellschaft nicht ganz so gut ist
früher war das bestimmt ein super
feature wenn ich ihnen mammut erlebt
habe war es bestimmt sinnvoll dass ich
davon mehrere wochen zählen konnte auch
wenn es danach dann nichts mehr gehabt
dann bin ich nicht sofort warum hat aber
heute haben wir ständig und immer und
überall etwas zu essen zur verfügung
und deswegen werden wir als westliche
gesellschaft immer dicker wie werden wir
diese fettreserven wieder los wenn wir
es denn wollen nun ganz einfach wir
stellen diesen prozess auf den kopf und
wir essen weniger als wir am tag
gebrauchen dann ist nämlich der körper
gezwungen an die fettreserven ranzugehen
und dieses fett wieder in energie
umzuwandeln
wir gehen also in einen kalorien defizit
wichtig ist an dieser stelle zu erwähnen
ein defizit klingt ungesünder als es
tatsächlich ist solange ihr alle eure
vitamine mineralstoffe und
spurenelemente bekommt ist das komplett
unbedenklich man sagt dass man so 10 bis
20 prozent seines kalorienbedarf ohne
probleme reduzieren kann trotzdem wenn
ihr irgendwelche erfahrungen schon
gemacht habe vielleicht probleme mit der
ernährung hatte durch generell unsicher
seid dann spricht auf jeden fall vorher
war doch ärztin oder arzt je weniger man
reduziert desto langsamer ist der
gewichtsverlust klar das hat man
wahrscheinlich am anfang das bedürfnis
möglichst viel gewicht zu verlieren und
deswegen ein möglichst großes defizit zu
machen aber davon würde ich euch
tatsächlich abraten das hat viele
vorteile
nur ein moderates defizit von vielleicht
15 oder sowas zu machen denn zum einen
hat man dann weniger hunger das ganze
kann man also einfach durchziehen man
wünscht sich irgendwann mal wieder und
zum anderen verliert man wahrscheinlich
weniger muskelmasse und verliert er
etwas tatsächlich am ende dann auch
besser aussieht und das tolle ist man
kann es nicht genau berechnen wie viel
man verlieren wird denn 7000
kilokalorien entsprechend ziemlich genau
einem kilogramm körperfett und genau das
habe ich tatsächlich auch als defizit
gehabt 1000 kalorien weniger am tag um
dann pro woche circa ein kilogramm zu
verlieren das ist ziemlich schnell und
ich wünsche euch auch ehrlich gesagt
nicht empfehlen aber was soll ich sagen
da habe ich halt gemacht nur 1000
kalorien weniger als was denn um das zu
beantworten muss man den eigenen
grundumsatz berechnen das ist die menge
an kalorien die mein körper im
normalbetrieb jeden tag braucht damit
ich ungefähr mein gewicht halte und das
hängt von super vielen faktoren ab in
erster linie spielen natürlich gewicht
größe geschlecht und alter eine rolle
dazu kommt dann was ich sonst nur mit
meinem körper mache aus war einfach zu
existieren an einem normalen tag sind
sich ja die meiste zeit am schreibtisch
und dabei verbrauchen ich natürlich
nicht so viel energie wie jemand der den
ganzen tag körperlich hart arbeitet denn
überraschungen anstrengende aktivitäten
nehmen uns wortwörtlich die energie
deswegen muss man in den grundumsatz
auch mit einberechnen wie oft und welche
art von sport man so betreibt und hier
habe ich etwas herausgefunden was mich
echt überrascht hat aber dazu kommen wir
gleich noch all diese werte und meinen
grund verbrauch festzulegen hat mich
übrigens keine ahnung eine viertelstunde
20 minuten gekostet es geht ganz einfach
online und alle links siehe dazu braucht
sind unten in der video beschreibung
verlängert dann habe ich mir noch eine
app heruntergeladen in die ich hab dann
alles eingetragen habe was ich sonst so
zu mir nehmen und dazu gehört natürlich
essen aber auch getränke wenn sie denn
kalorien haben also fast alles außer
wasser übrigens auch alkohol davon gibt
viele verschiedene apps ich habe euch
einfach mal 23 unten verlinkten habt ihr
eine gewisse auswahl wenn jetzt noch
mehr zu diesem thema fracking erfahren
wollt warum ich das mache und was sich
sonst noch so alles trecker dann schaut
euch doch mal dieses video hier an dass
wir schon vor ein paar monaten gemacht
haben und dann war ich auch schon über
die job
ich habe tatsächlich den spannenden
effekt bemerkt dass ich viel mehr darauf
achten was ich esse und ich habe sowieso
schon durch den opfern viel mehr
angefangen zu kochen mache jetzt aber
noch mehr und experimentiere mehr um mit
meiner waage und was vom rhein ist
manchmal wirklich beim kochen dass man
immer alles abbiegen muss sowas aber es
geht total und ich bin mal gespannt wie
es weiter geht es gerade das erste mal
dass ich mich so komplett sehe seit
einiger zeit und es auch das erstmals
aufgefallen ist ist passiert war es
tatsächlich also man ist ja so sein
selbstbild ein bisschen gewohnt wird
hiervon lange laufen und hab gedacht so
[Musik]
ich werde dünner tatsächlich
meine position experiment ist und einen
sport maxx im moment vorgegangen mach
jetzt andere verträge große reparatur
verbessert jetzt leider sehr unser
kalorien ein
bisschen mehr als fünf wochen ich bin
wesentlich schneller als ich gedacht
hätte wahrscheinlich zu schnell mein
nächstes ziel für die nächsten wochen
ist jetzt tatsächlich ein bisschen zu
reduzieren weil aktuell wenig bei
ungefähr 1,4 kilogramm pro woche die ich
abnehme und dass es zuviel gerade aber
ganz ehrlich dafür dass es so gut
funktioniert ich mach mehr sport als ich
vorher gemacht habe ich es gesünder als
ich vorher gegessen habe und ich habe
nicht mal wirklich großen hunger ich hab
das ja keine fressattacken ich hatte
keine probleme das einzuhalten
aktuellste erfolgserlebnis ist ich
musste meine güte länger machen
[Musik]
kalorien zählen update april
ich habe innerhalb von sieben wochen 13
kilo und bin jetzt bei 83,4 mir geht's
gut also ich will jetzt nicht hinstellen
sagen ich bin so fit wie nie zuvor oder
somit zugleich wie aller zeiten aber
keiner mir geht's gut vor allem also so
so oberflächlich das auch ist ich glaube
ich sie besser aus und ich mir sagen
leute dass ich besser aussehen das geht
tatsächlich grad am meisten
selbstwertgefühl und ich glaube das
größte weil ich berichten kann ist dass
es euch inzwischen aufgefallen ist also
es fällt wohl auf und es macht auch was
mit meinem aussehen meine ernährung ist
umgestellt meine hits haben sich
verändert ich es jetzt keine süße oder
fast gar kein ich kenne ich habe
überhaupt kein nutella managers und
seitdem ich habe keinen kakao mehr
getrunken ich bin schon mal sehr
gespannt wie es nach bewohner sein wird
wenn man mal wieder rausgehen kann man
kann das restaurant gehen und dann kann
man nicht in eine vage mitbringen und
die chips die man beim filmegucken ist
messen ihr seht dass auf manchen dieser
aufnahmen die waage war und ist mein
ständiger begleiter ich habe mich selber
aber auch mein essen gewogen ohne jedes
nicht hallo eine kleine und eine große
pommes oder
auch wenn ich in manchen sachen
mittlerweile ziemlich gut mit dem auge
einschätzen kann wie die ich wirklich
ausnahmslos angst das ist einfach super
schwierig zu sagen was wie viel das wird
ihr zum beispiel schätzen sind das hier
anders dass die kleine pommes das ist
die große klar aber wir sind das ich
sag's euch das sind 150 gramm und das
sind 80 gramm und es sieht auf den
ersten blick relativ ähnlich aus das
schlimme ist das macht einen kalorien
unterschied von 200 kilokalorien direkt
aus und ich dass ich das hier nehme und
das ist mal eben zehn prozent von meinem
gesamten tages gedreht oder mein
komplettes defizit wenn ich es etwas
moderater angehen lassen jetzt werden
wahrscheinlich einige von euch sagen
dass man wahrscheinlich sowieso keine
pommes essen sollte wenn man gerade auf
diät ist weil das eher ungesund ist aber
genau das ist ja das tolle am
kalorienzählen es ist eigentlich völlig
egal wie man sein tages damit erreicht
man muss nicht gesund essen um
abzunehmen wenn ich meinen tages
durchschnitt nur mit pommes erreiche und
danach ja ich esse dann wie du das
ungefähr so aussehen aber noch ein
bisschen ketchup mayo dazu wenn ich nur
dass hier am tag essen würde dann wird
wahrscheinlich richtig scheiße gehen
aber dann würde ich abnehmen kalorien
sind kalorien egal ob pommes pizza oder
eis oder spinat und apfel egal ob
kohlenhydrate proteine oder fett der
große vorteil einer gesünderen ernährung
ist dass sich schneller und
langanhaltender sagt ja da von
ballaststoffen kann ich eben einfach
mehr volumen zu mir nehmen nach zwei
pizzen und einem großen glas cola wäre
für mich bereits mein kalorien damit
erreicht und das hält mich definitiv
nicht den ganzen tag lang satt aber mit
viel gemüse oder obst kann ich mich
richtig voll schaufeln und dann habe ich
immer noch platz für ein schokoriegel
oder sowas wenn man aber keine lust
hatte super gesund zu essen und der
hunger nach zwei tiefkühlpizzen immer
noch da ist dann kann man natürlich auch
einfach den grundumsatz erhöhen und das
geahnt ist macht man zum beispiel mit
sport das habe auch ich relativ schnell
gemacht jetzt könnte man natürlich sagen
dass das ein bisschen die werte verzerrt
weil ich ja schließlich nicht nur
kalorienzähler aber die auswirkungen von
sport sind tatsächlich ziemlich
umstritten das komplett zu erklären
würde jetzt hier ein bisschen im rahmen
sprengen vielleicht machen wir das
irgendwann mal noch ein eigenes video
aber deswegen hier erstmal die
kurzfassung was glaubt ihr wer braucht
mehr kalorien jäger und sammler eines
tansanischen stammes oder jemand der den
ganzen tag hinterm schreibtisch sitzt
richtig keiner von beiden trotz eines
super aktiven lifestyles haben die jäger
und sammler nicht nennenswert mehr
kalorien durch ihre bewegung verbracht
das hat eine studie herausgefunden
trotzdem sind diese menschen im schnitt
viel dünner als der typische
büroarbeiter der westlichen welt und das
liegt einfach nur daran dass sie nicht
mehr essen als sie benötigen also sport
ist ein super weg ein längeres und
gesünderes leben zu führen sport macht
spaß und wir alle sollten unbedingt mehr
sportler
aber um abzunehmen ist die ernährung
viel viel wichtiger man kann problemlos
sein wunschgewicht erreichen ohne auch
nur einmal sport gemacht zu haben
empfehlen würde ich das nicht aber das
dazu so zurück zum thema
[Musik]
genauso wichtig wie man essen zu wiegen
ist es gewesen mich selber zu wiegen am
besten jeden tag nach dem aufstehen
bevor man irgendwas zu sich genommen hat
und nach dem toilettengang
denn dann sieht man am besten die trends
wenn ich das nur einmal die woche mache
dann kann das schon ganz schön
unübersichtlich werden aber keine panik
wenn das an manchen tagen auf der waage
mai nicht haargenau so eintreten sollte
wie vorher berechnet denn jeder körper
ist anders und manchmal entscheidet sich
unser körper aus den verschiedensten
gründen salz alkohol der zyklus etwas
mehr wasser zu speichern und das sorgt
dafür dass man mal ein bisschen mehr
oder auch weniger wiegen kann aber das
tolle ist wenn man richtig kalorien
zählt und sich nicht selber belügt dann
nimmt man auf dauer genau das ab was man
vorher berechnet hat das war bei mir
über wochen hinweg unglaublich
konsistent wenn man die
durchschnittswerte nimmt und apropos
wiegen damit kommen wir auch schon zu
der großen frage wie gut hat kalorien
zählen bei mir funktioniert
einigen von euch ist es ja schon in den
kommentaren aufgefallen also keine große
überraschung ich habe einiges an gewicht
durch kalorien ziel und verloren aber
wie viel genau das finden wir jetzt
heraus ok acht monate knapp 500.000
kalorien und über 500 mahlzeiten ich
habe jeder einzelnen kalorien gezählt
und jetzt will ich mal sehen was es
gebracht hat
[Musik]
79,1 was da ist das ist das wo ich sein
will kann bis zum em geht immer und so
was aber ich bin jetzt auch seit einiger
zeit dabei muskeln aufzubauen deswegen
ist das gewicht sowie sowohl sind ganz
akkurat für mich ist einfach wichtig
dass ich mich in meinem körper gut fühle
und das tue ich das
[Musik]
aber ich kann nicht sagen es ist ein
unglaublich gutes gefühl
das kontrollieren zu können für den für
mein ganzes leben lang konnte ich nie
kontrollieren wie ich aussehe und wie
vidic ich bin und ich habe klar ich habe
dann sport gemacht und ich hätte weniger
essen können aber ich bin nie wirklich
weg gekommen von dem was ich wie ich aus
gesehen habe und jetzt habe ich das
gefühl ich habe verstanden was dahinter
ist ich hab die kontrolle darüber ich
kann sagen dass ich weiter abnehmen
möchte und dann mache ich das einfach
indem ich halt meine kalorienzähler und
weniger esse ich kann jetzt auf menschen
zugehen wenn ich wollte könnte ich jetzt
genau bei meinen 79,6 gehen nicht genau
ich könnte jetzt bei 79 kilogramm
ungefähr bleiben plus/minus 1 kilo wenn
ich jetzt waren sie auf 2500 bis 2600
also auf meine maintenance level gier
ich könnte auch wieder zunehmen wenn ich
das will ich habe die komplette
kontrolle über meinem körper was ich
früher nicht hatte und das ist ein
cooles gefühl eins ist mir noch ganz
wichtig zu sagen auch wenn bei mir alles
gut lief so krass auf die ernährung zu
achten kann dazu führen dass man ein
ungesundes verhältnis zu essen
entwickelt deswegen ist es wie ich finde
wichtig beim trekking auch mal fünfe
gerade sein zu lassen nur weil man gerne
einen 500 kilokalorien defizit jeden tag
hätte heißt es nicht dass man sofort
zunimmt wären noch mal zwei bis drei
tage über diesem limit glied auch wenn
ich nur 100 kilokalorien unter dem
umsatz liege nehme ich ja immer noch ab
nur eben nicht ganz so schnell und das
ist ja eigentlich auch ganz gut so nicht
vergessen essen darf auch spaß machen
und es ist auch lecker und es muss nicht
immer in einer energie kosten nutzen
rechnung aufgehen meine wichtigste regel
war dass ich mich im sozialen kontext
nie eingeschränkt habe also wenn ich
irgendwie mit freunden unterwegs war
oder sowas dann habe ich zwar kalorien
gezählt meistens auch im nachhinein das
war doch noch nicht ganz so genau und
mit dem abendessen und dem bier war ich
dann noch über meinem limit aber so what
dann ging es eben am nächsten tag weiter
gesunde gewichtsabnahme und auch gesunde
gewichtszunahme geschieht langfristig
ich habe meine ernährung umgestellt und
ich bin mir auch deswegen ziemlich
sicher dass ich mein gewicht halten
werde das war keine julio diät trotzdem
wenn man dann nach langem tracking das
wunschgewicht erreicht hat ist es auch
wichtig zu verstehen dass man irgendwann
auch mal wieder zunehmen könnte der
trick ist hier gar nicht zu denken ach
jetzt bin ich fertig jetzt kann ich
endlich wieder so viel essen wie ich
schon immer wollte
stattdessen muss man weiter auf seine
ernährung achten und vielleicht sogar
eine zeit lang auch weiter kalorien
zählen entweder aktiv oder ob sie wie
ich das jetzt mache im kopf und mit
groben schätzungen und auch wichtig
natürlich bedeutet dünner nicht gleich
besser oder schöner es ist vollkommen
okay nicht drin zu sein und es ist doch
vollkommen ok sich wohlzufühlen mit
übergewicht oder untergewicht so lange
dass keine gesundheitlichen auswirkungen
auf euch hat und das gleiche gilt auch
für die geistige gesundheit wenn ihr
eine vergangenheit mit essstörungen habt
oder euch nicht wohl damit fühlt dann
geht die geistige gesundheit vor
essstörungen sind ernstzunehmende
lebensbedrohliche krankheiten und falls
ihr damit hilfe sucht haben wir für euch
in der video beschreibung auch einiges
an informativen und hilfreichen links
falls sie jetzt trotzdem denkt das
kalorienzählen etwas für euch sein
könnte und wir das mal ausprobieren
wollt dann kann ich euch nur die daumen
drücken und sagen viel erfolg ich würde
ich total gerne noch unglaublich viele
tipps geben und erfahrungen die ich in
letzten monaten so gesammelt habe
allerdings reicht die zeit in diesem
video hier leider nicht aus ist sowieso
schon so mega lang geworden ich packe
euch mal wieder eine video beschreibung
einige links zu fuhren die mir geholfen
haben vor allem zur editoren die sind
dann auf englisch aber da sind wirklich
echt tolle tipps und man kann auch
fragen stellen kriegt eine ganz tolle
community die einen da unterstützt und
wie gesagt mein gewicht ist ja nicht das
einzige was ich strecke darüber haben
wir schon ein video gemacht falls euch
dafür interessiert wie ich auch noch
mein glück und mein geld strecke dann
könnt ihr euch das hier anschauen viel
spaß bei dem video ansonsten wie immer
vielen dank fürs zuschauen und bis zum
nächsten mal bleibt neugierig cedric